[Music]
which is better
object-oriented or functional
programming how about composition or
inheritance semicolons or no semicolons
is it pronounced Jif or gif and is a hot
dog of sandwich today you'll get all the
answers and I encourage you to just
accept these as the facts and not try
out anything on your own there's only
one correct way to write code and if
there's one thing that employers hate
it's creative problem-solving skills
from their programmers if you're new
here like and subscribe and congrats to
Alexander Torres here the random t-shirt
winner from last week and a huge thank
you to Patrick Neal Lou
he contributed to the content of this
video and has helped out hundreds if not
thousands of developers on our slack
Channel so make sure to spam him with a
thank you message let's go ahead and
take care of the easy ones first when
writing your code you should leave some
Mikael arms out and then have prettier
add them back when you save the file gif
stands for graphics interchange format
so it's obviously pronounced gift
following the first word in the acronym
itself is a hot dog sandwich well that
one's a little more complex so let's
wait till the end of the video
how about object-oriented versus
functional programming
if you guessed object-oriented is better
you're completely wrong and if you
guessed functional programming you're
way off base debating programming
paradigms at this level is like debating
art there is always more than one way to
solve a problem especially in JavaScript
and it's great to debate these things
but there are no absolutes there's going
to be a trade-off for every decision
that you make let's start by taking a
look at some functional typescript code
the most important concept in functional
programming is the concept of pure
functions this means that the output of
your function should only depend on its
inputs for example here we have a
function called two string which takes a
value as its argument and then returns
that value formatted as a string we can
make this an impure function by mutating
the number variable directly this would
be considered a side-effect and
functional code should produce no
side-effects in addition they should not
rely on any outside value to produce a
return value pure functions are easier
to test and also easier to reason about
because you don't have to think about
anything happening outside of the
function itself another core principle
of functional programming is immutable
data functional code is stateless
meaning that when data is created
it is never mutated for example we can
simulate this in JavaScript by using
object freeze on this array of numbers
we could hack around this but it
prevents us from doing things like a
right push which you wouldn't do in a
functional program so obviously our data
has to change somehow if we have a
dynamic software application so you'll
often be passing functions as arguments
to other functions so here we have a
typical first order function which takes
a value and returns a different value in
this case just appending an emoji to a
string now a higher-order function is
one that either takes a function as an
argument or it turns a function itself
javascript has some really nice built-in
higher-order functions for arrays such
as map so instead of using a for loop we
can just pass in our function to map
which will run our add emoji function on
every element in the array and transform
the value so that gives us a very
concise and elegant way to transform the
values in an array another cool thing we
can do is create functions that return
functions this is very useful when you
want to start with some base
functionality and then extend it with
some dynamic data let's imagine we're
building a weather app and we need to
append strings with certain emojis we'll
start with a base function called append
emoji and then use it to compose more
complex functions so in this case the
inner function takes both of the
arguments and adds them together we can
use this to create more specialized
functions that point to a specific emoji
for example we'll have a rain function
and a Sun function then we can call this
function with the string that we want
the emoji appended to the end result is
some concise and readable code that
doesn't rely on any shared state that
would make it difficult to test that's
about as basic as it gets for functional
programming and things get a lot more
interesting when you have asynchronous
data and side-effects and things like
that
so now let's go ahead and compare this
to object-oriented programming the best
comparison I've seen is to a baking
recipe I'll have a link to that in the
description the object-oriented or
imperative approach on the top gives you
a clear set of statements to follow to
get the cake to its final state the
functional or declarative approach on
the bottom describes the state and logic
involved but has no opinion on the
actual control flow now let's go ahead
and look at some object-oriented
typescript code the first thing we'll do
is define a class which itself doesn't
really do anything but rather it serves
as a blue
print for instantiating objects so an
instance of this emoji class will be an
object with an icon property then the
constructor method is special because it
runs once when the object is
instantiated will pass an argument to
the constructor with the actual emoji
icon and then we'll set that equal to
the property on this object and the
emoji class works similar to a function
but we use the new keyword in front of
it and as you can see when we do that it
creates the an emoji object with an icon
property of Sun in typescript there's an
easier way to do this because we have
the concept of public and private
members so if we use the public key word
in front of the argument in the
constructor typescript will
automatically know to set that as a
public property on each object when you
declare a property or method public it
means it's available to the class itself
and any instances of the class that can
be both a good and a bad thing for
example we can simply change the icon by
just mutating the value on its object on
one hand it's very convenient but on the
other hand if you have a lot of code
doing this it can be hard to keep track
of and hard to test effectively I'd like
to point out at this point that classes
in JavaScript are actually just
syntactic sugar for functions and
prototype one heritance
if we can pile our code to yes three you
can see that it's just a function with a
closure that prevents the local
variables from bleeding out into the
global scope that's just something to be
aware of but typescript also provides
some tools for us to improve the tone
that we have when writing
object-oriented code for example we can
mark members as private so that they can
only be used inside of this class
definition this means that we can
separate our public API from internal
logic for this class for example if we
want to make this icon value and mutable
we can make it private and we'll define
a getter so the user can read the value
but not change the value another
important thing to point out here is
that class instances can have their own
internal state let's imagine we have a
button where the user can toggle the
emoji and maybe go back and forth
between different states this is a
really simple thing to implement an
object-oriented programming will add
another private property to this class
called previous and then use a getter to
retrieve that value then we'll define a
change method which will mutate the
actual icon value on this instance when
that happens we'll first change the
previous value to the current icon and
then update the current icon to the new
value on the first console log we get
the Sun icon and undefined and if we
mutate the state a couple times you can
see that our internal values on this
class instance have changed so the end
result is that we have a class that's
encapsulated all the logic for how an
emoji should work and with typescript we
automatically have an interface and
documentation for this class another
cool thing you can do with classes is
define static methods the unique thing
about a static method is that it's on
the class itself and not an instance of
a class so we'll just go ahead and
define a static method here which itself
is actually a pure function and its job
is simply to add one to the input
argument the cool thing is that we can
now use the Emoji class as a namespace
to run this function now we're going to
switch gears and talk about composition
versus inheritance for code reusability
this is an area where people tend to get
very strong opinions and the actual
definition of composition tends to be a
little convoluted but the whole thing
really just boils down to this with
inheritance you start with a larger base
class then have child classes inherit
all of this functionality and override
or extend it with whatever custom
behaviors that they need composition on
the other hand breaks apart the
interfaces and logic into a lot of small
pieces then builds up larger functions
or objects by combining these pieces
together let's go ahead and take a look
at an example of inheritance we start
with the class of human that has a
public property of name and has the
ability to say hi but what if we have a
lot of other objects in our program that
are similar but implement slightly
different features based on what they're
designed to do for example in a video
game you might have a human character
and then a super human character that
has all the human abilities but with a
little something extra in typescript we
can simply inherit all the functionality
from the human class by saying super
human extends human we do have an
argument in the constructor so we'll
also need to add that to the constructor
without private or public then we call
super which will execute the code in the
constructor of the parent class which in
our case is just initializing this name
property at this point we'll go ahead
and define an additional method called
super power then we'll create an
instance of the super human class and
what you'll see here is that it has this
or power method whereas the regular
human does not but the superhuman can
still call all the methods that were
defined in the parent class inheritance
can be great in the right situation but
you want to avoid creating really deeply
nested classes because it becomes very
hard to debug when things go wrong
somewhere in the middle as an
alternative we can use composition and
there are actually multiple different
ways we can apply this pattern in
angular we can do it by injecting
services into our components and also at
the template level by creating
directives I'm not going to cover that
here but it's just one of the awesome
things about angular that I've covered
in many other videos another alternative
is to concatenate objects together which
I've seen covered in several different
articles on the web the idea here is
that you decouple your properties or
behaviors into objects or functions that
return objects we can then merge all
these objects together into a final
function that does everything that we
need it to this is usually referred to
as a mixin pattern and it's just a
certain type of multiple inheritance so
the terminology between composition and
inheritance is sort of convoluted in any
case this mixin pattern can be very
powerful but in its current form we lose
all of the ergonomics of class-based
object-oriented programming that might
be a good or bad thing depending on who
you ask
but typescript actually gives us the
flexibility to use mix-ins in a
class-based format first I'm going to
pull in this really ugly function from
the typescript Docs which we'll see in
use here in just a minute from there I'm
going to create a couple of small
behavior classes that define the
individual behaviors instead of trying
to encapsulate everything in a single
class so these classes are more
concerned with what something does
instead of what something is now in the
superhero class there's a very subtle
difference from the previous example
instead of extending the class we are
going to implement multiple classes when
you implement something you're only
concerned about its interface and not
its underlying code it's the apply
mix-ins function that we defined at the
very beginning that will actually take
these interfaces and apply their code to
this class that does leave us with some
extra boilerplate code where we have to
actually type the return values on the
methods for this class in this case we
have two methods say hi and super power
both of which return strings and the
final step is the requirement to call
that apply mix-ins function with the
base classes the first
and the mixed in classes as the second
argument now we can finally answer the
question is a hot dog a sandwich if you
use inheritance then you're going to
have to inherit from some base sandwich
class which means it is a sandwich but
if you use composition then you can just
pull in the hot dog in the bun meaning
that it is not a sandwich I'm gonna go
ahead and wrap things up there if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and I just want to say thank
you to everybody for an amazing 2018 I'm
super grateful for the community around
this channel and I look forward to
pushing things even further in 2019 I'm
going to be taking a short break for the
next couple of weeks and then I have a
video plan for January 1st so stay tuned
for that I hope everybody has an awesome
end of the year and you can still find
me on slack if you have any questions or
need anything at all thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you soon
[Music]